але назвати і сергей квіт міністра
святі науки та
у нашій прес-конференції все нашого
брифінгу березі часто кішки нормально
салон вона польщею заступник бе беше
заступник і так вже
вже вирішено товариство наше наш брифінг
even освіченою першим став днями та
ряду так як наше міністерство матчів
цепеш джерело і ми вже 3 і попроси вали
подавилася сенаті процеси
як панує буваєте я прибивається документа
відпочинок прийняття рішення я прочитають люди
ось я до реакції грамоти кісток там про
за раз уже з перспективи такого великого
управлінську та зведу, але я можу
сказати що нібито більшим у нашої більше
100 днів
porsche дуже важливо видно в цій до
віру граматика стиду а міністерство
святі нових осіб і дуже важливо я хочу
переслати 1000 всього міністерстві
процедурі дуже багато а профі сильних
чесних та порядних людей це довга
стосувалося а що це міністерство на нас
кріс курапова на я думаю собі правильно
і
ті корупції не схеми які bull і в
компетенції тіла міністерства та з нас
тусується різьбленому вигляді в реальності в мфц
при падінні від і
щоб наші з витян та наш бюджет уже не
будуть так страшно ти я зберігаєш і ось але
я б не сказав ще ми в рамках наших
таких нам рифу навести ілюстрацію від і
ви його ти всі ці процеси ми
завершуємо зі своїми фокусами уваги якщо ми
продовжуватимемо про роботу топ то завдання
номер один циві тиску довели до
нашого міністерства інші цілі keys
стратегічні плани деякими maemo до вас
церкви яки
я прикольний вени з вини на устілці в
play ноти на нашу середню split ноту
щоб
мотай pattern виворот її характер вона
наперед характер його не може доглядач
до цього ачивки
і т.д. я ще люди самі це наша
спеціальність самі не захоче закинути
нас приємних обставлено але по 1000
power that is a до передніх правил
ігри до таких стратегічних номерів
носиться прийняття закону про вищого
світла і мету закон були винесені на
розвинений верховної ради через тричі
на доступний планарний тричі нацизм
законом освітимо sky граматики та
питала астані і я думаю 2 повних
рокки з так званий закон групою
сваровського ми завжди не виходило і з
був і з витян її, і просто онуки дурень і
про spylog студентських організацій
Національної академії наук процедури тут
вже була душа душа великою предна робота
з нею світячи низькою грамотою кістки і я
думаю проникати його закону право ще
свиту в новий але замінить і всі правила
ігри вище і світить атоми по війні і ти
шляхом інтеграції від зайве конкретно
знатності наших вищих начальниця окладі
хтось закон перевищує свиту це вин до 21
наших стратегічних на світі таким самим
ми протестуємо вона драм до вас законом про
святу кита кожну
важливі вояки будуть арка тася засіки
середні святі топ то ці законопроекти
це можливо
у законотворчості з наші наші персики
тоді напиши я прошу червові сажки
завдання 1100 суйся середнього почту
на самому порід я б хотіли значить і
суперечить оптом і по ви не зміните
систему і ми вже багато в чому я до самої
видаватимуться підручнику
від сонячних вологість і його не я її
прилад не золоті на лижному ченом і тут
ми maemo колишні проблеми з в'язання
стем рахунок серег досить вашке ось і
сонячно повинен оцінювання ми думали
тиснути сумі сором і так я зберігаєш це
було в тему роті
ланцюга сумка і безрукавок заради цього
статті про простіше та зони складним синього
ніл натисканні на його можна ще про емме
процеси ви не було б ти кордон
тіні запущені раніше вони ж будете
алея попереднього там ти це буде по
три але ми будемо максимально з простіше ось
ці api целкова атестацію для того
щоб випускники шкіл ванни та нормально
себе пригощав іван мінерву волосся там
ще ви знаєте ще в різних регіонах
україна ситуація і була і завищується
дощок на пружини там і ми давайте
себе і ми будемо зірки
радійте і cc ключовий момент про що ми
повинні будемо радіти
посвіти натякав і банан прям зречься
навіть важливі рішення і нормально зараз
скажи про акредитацію за цим та у своєму
такому короткому насилу умови також
хочу згорнути його гол на проблеми
присвятимо криму нашому міністерстві
відкрита гаряча лінія на світлому фоні
гаряча лінія за раз можна назвати авось
і телефон так вже можна знайти на нашому
сайті його номер 481 3211
і ящики з таких ніг її харчування
індивідуальних ще людей хвалю та допомогою
захід і різьбленого характеру і я одягаюсь
ще розхвалювали слюда йдете захід і
таки того
не води але не з вини провести vegas
паніку там ще я хочу під крісло 1000
міністерство світло та науки будете назвати
зустрічей і буде допомагати індивідуально
у кожному на жаль тортуру призу потах наших
батьки хід учинивши обидва студенти мої
будні хобі турніки випуск таких шкіл
сіємо працюючи яким краще топ-3 до
ситуації он і витратив і від і ми будемо
до допомагати їх симптоми на переживає їм
з вами і ми спину ви вдома і з усієї
ситуації та та це це дуже і ту ж важливу
і щоб у нас була мета позики взаємо
розуміння і так 1 vira 1 до 1
також ви знаєте ці поди у нас і зарості
б увійти в криму
від ситуації це кішка на nano sim opel
astra його на душі тривожно ось і тому й
у нас такі сигнали ще сама про калоші
на владу
автономної республіки крим банана
приклад травня на світ ви дати випускникам
шкіл
російські сертифікати чинять і якісь
еньші такі крихти кіма 4 провокативний
характер ми будемо і ригу вати на все
такі з проби
вниз ти такі зумієте
в жити а осетинської кульгати і кістки і
наших студентів і врахувавши ось цього в
буде вмирати і міністерство світла і
науки України будуть на ходу цієї повії
виходу з подібних ситуацій може
витягуватись сяду нас і ми будемо сука ти
син повії і бск вам допоможемо а також я
хотів би згорнути ісятда кримчан
ви знаєте за раз українські канали вид
ключі не в криму
я так розумію ще можна його мої слова
може дітей через музику через інтернет
люди через розлад з інтернету ми ж
широко інформації студенти можна
увійшли ось не вертай про це все
інформатики вимиє з офіційного
російського ти чи чині нажаль у росії
таки державні фактично рибалити і
тільки табачники вона летить до нього на все
офіційне і в нього представляється за
чекає на думку і натиснути задумка яко
уявляєте проводиться для України
парку та в засіки
вона не правда його топ то в Києві ніхто
нікого не переслідуючи в Києві люди
посміхнулися у нас весна сонце ще ви
приїде і
і пройшовши порожнини києва побачила рахунки за
всіма що жити, а ми вигнали тирана столітті
побувавши на краю ну і 1000 видується за раз
натиснули в криму cs проби вас отримає їжу
і шиїти раніше, щоб у вас не було
свободи слова, щоб вас не було
університетської автономії
ще б вижив і за членами творене за
завидною завісою цельсія недобре і я
думаю з роботи свій правильний вибір
і подумайте ще з Україною про вас чекають
великі позитивні зміни цифри міни
свободи топ то ми за кликаємо вас ви брат
і свободу і за кликаємо озу крима
студентів мислять і критично і подивитись
до в колосі б застосовувати ці інформатики
вимиє з різьблених jarrell
ось і наш з офіційних російських
каналі в зовсім дрімучих від за
вивчаємо всі ціни ходи
такого чесного негативно
пропагандистську машину ось мислити
критично і подумає і потрібно вам
свобода чого хоче і все жити і жити
і син і желейного чоловічка маяки
знаків означає хто вони такі захопили
крим і перспектива жити, якщо ми зеленим
чоловічкам і перспектива ще дити ваші
також води будуть такими зеленими
чоловічками майбутньому з погано
перспектива я думаю ще светр свободи
типі рамена які і за раз в Україні
ванни і також вашими перспективами і
безпосередньо вона формується з наших
политих у міністерства святі науки ще
ми за тисячу б не втручати і ми за те
щоб не висоти для контролю вати
ось і не прям уже а ось і це наша головна
політика та
головному це реальності нашого
міністерства це як є про свята ки
середню святу кисть вище і святий і я
кріс і головне все ще ми будемо 3 мда
допомагати і ми зніматимемо з оборони і
кібли створі не натиснули по стрибні годинник і
ми будемо вас простіше ватою зі своїм або
зв'язування ми будемо access простіше у цій
темці думаєте про я кисті кіпру сюїти
текке просіть творчо
будь то знатними хресту і тіся
автономію та
c тіла на початку жити в основі в основі
нашої політики я зараз завершую свої
особливі слова і хочу міста ти слову і
не романі sassoon ласкам до рівня
шановний журналіста я рада 8 то ти
сьогодні я коротко також розкуримо продажів
чим владно займається за раз але ігри на
sony star зі свитою наука та я думаєш
вичавлював із мало знайомі з планом де
можна видачу деталі зуя що саме
вигадуєте
нас тішить вже в посмішці
працюєте за розлучаються в ікону в це
пов'язані
з картами на папороті рен це
порушенням реальності
рибу насправді де їхала річки тут
ми збережемо корінні 100 міністерство
святі наука тільки за сьогодні вдома не
прийшло 4 різних людей на так то за
запасом та хто просто дуже просив і
тому що дайсона законно закрила
університет days кому з 2 рок-н і ви
даєте сертифікат для відривання коли
дольського ступня та ще є дисертації
на вм з нас політичних заходів щодо не
відправляють на колективний експорт за
Юлю дурням відсікають знайти рішення то з
таким оскаром люди проходять нехай і ну і
c&c нас чи правдиві якісно роботи
на різниці новація дізнатися чим у цієї
кому ременя була допущена смітниках то все
мумінін найгірший випадок на голову
спрямовано краще вижити на по
правильному королівстві і я колись допоміг
цим людям ці сорти ються син такі великі
шмат працюєте за раз вижити на новому
корінні серце святі наука надягаємо
осушимо відому проблему сяо ladies ну
scarf над ходіть назву чайного лика кіль
кістки краще вийми її підвищення які
навички ранку час від часу можна змінити це
колагену ці два університети та образу
травень але одне важливе починає розпродавати
та дострибну так exprof багату та ми на
різним активно про тюрму бути ви парижа
youtube це не я скажу відразу всі кола
з конкретного прикладу сьогодні ми не
будемо а каже цьому що на плями
чіткий your вдалий аналіз і до інших
можна буду, а волосся-то називав просушу
дату яблуня про те ці спади до нас
дістався в міністерстві святі
годину дуже важливо плутати xxx карти кит
у нас надходите по метро ти про
стратегічні ricci
Терачина такими іншого треба ким їм
і владні прийшли до міністерства святі
наука і там у нас було навіть важливе вас
клас ти владно наш класний план 9
по дну стратегією що ми на потонув і в
потокових праворуч h-moll і чіткої
план дівчини того що але я прийду на
роботу і я краби ти знаєш ти як на
одноразово вирвалася ще одним з
важливих купуйте я за забезпечення
максимально ганьба та бухгалтерії
публікації онлайн бюджет ви датськи його
апарат у мене царство світла та наука
я звалюю сушитися в жабу, то запущу нас
паршиво quite не на розжуйте
аякса митися можна труби ти технічно з
прикро складно з точки зору публічності
і прозоровський думаю, що будуть вже важливо
навколо річки втягне всією рамадана і us
within та
і відчуваєш і чим рядів текке порадує
нас вухам практику так само в нас уже
купа
дієти фінансовий аудит 100 ват та дружина
фінансова вода то й до і була детально
документа вікі за вишилася а натиснули
всезнайок за вишилася а
оладки за вишилася а дивлюся ви обидва ти
типу руйнування річки або збувалося а
підніму кору в дитинстві ми повчав і
іншого ти вдома вшиваються навіть великі
проекти можна колишніх 100 денна досьє про
повністю запустити головну провину за
пустує електронний документ обох
тому що небудь хороше що ми на
особливий 100 фраза вокалу я пройшла в
кабінет а ось така стопка гумка я
здається за є на стільці міністра
нас цілей паршиво доступних і нижчих
заступники ці трави проти ти
подавитеся арус по сатани еньші хтось
porsche євро ж не складається ніж
займається міністерство до відриву
алістеру сенс і на канальців збору
інформацію розсилаючи і так далі і в
таких умовах колу міністерство так
проти і настільки завантажити спробую
роботу викопана про те, що те
міністерством вже ніби крем із реальним
суб'єктом політичну deer реальним
суб'єктом та розрубаю та ліфті любовну
стратегію формування зведенню кулі
так і просто на motion його цьому дуже
важливим пріоритетом на різання ґрунтовок з
простіше для процесу просто через
електронний документ про лобі також знаємо
що це просто кілька з татом ребеккі
повинен відходять від міністерства на
становище між за раз міністерство впало
на пугачова ти просто на нього повернути чи
кістер і чай вже година тут вже формальні
лякати дженерики разом стоїмо забирають
робочий годинник забирають по внизу сировини і
так далі я до речі вийшли знятий цей
сюжет менший
описах по парі вікі просто проходу через
міністерство і тим самим вивернеться
просто робоча година противники в для того
щоб лаз на працюючи кусь аналітику
розробка стратегії політика і так
далі так далі на rosieres їхніх убавок він
у міністерства точно забув когось типу
парову роботу заробивши ок точно їм
вузли
ensure a china таким же про в'язницю з два
моменту в плані гроші було три молотки
за ну що стає з косово нібіру
карткових наказів до міністерства світла та
наука та keepass бабло не управлінського
з місця та визнаний заліза with nasty та
владна популярність дуже багато
та вивчаємо на нам послугу саут-енд лижний
спорт це абсолютно все вона, ніж вас
пасторальний зараз я просив c
з простіше не суді вас прощення процедур
ліцензування та акредитації та
з простіше не процедури нострифікації вже в
польоті лак на сайті міністерства святі
наука
будуть при столах для граматика
займання та концепція ліцензування
гід за відомим накази запланованим
зрадами та
Концепція реформування на острів
процедури нострифікації в парашу торгую
нострифікації озвучено планується з
минулого таїться
вибуху в наших шинах закону поля, що дав
хоч крок для випускників у захисних
університеті тут він видно купа-купа ціна
монтажу не знаєш це з просто це
процес і нострифікації для tedx
випускники вина за інших програм річки
кидаються в Україну відому
суді вас простіше дня і суді ви значення по
прогалини як будете після ухвалення закону
про вашу свиту ми надягаємо ще у Польщі
муджі танець і тут знайти шляхом ти ж не
2 buderus я dataset фаршем обліку не
законопроект перевищує почет якщо тіло
теж оперативну на плями йдуть
вата деки змін і пропустити їжу змін
запобігти законопроекту до іншого
джедая
таким же нам чорно кіно темряви сни мото
абсолютно нову закону дала рамку
чортовий від мого насильницького то ви
зараз вид а якщо тіол відомо можна
майбутнє більше попит ти знаєш ця
кирка та спокою раббі ви і так далі
тому що свистну законопроект
дубровський ведений за свою масову
інформації прокачай значно більшу
автономію найбільш реальність для великих
початкових закладі розум стем душ добрий
розуміємо і що просто треба тій автономії
нашим ти париш ним університетом ніби
мало що сильно так у нових call та
ректором нічний світ і не довіряєте
нічний світ та акулою мало приклади
голови моєму приклади корупції на ремені
україна найгірших початкових закладів на
пляма запас шануй що буде автономія
половинку в'язальну прозорець кольоровий
рамаданом так так що ми намагаємося за
раз запустить і на ремені міністерство
публікації всієї бухгалтерської
уїдливості навіть спуді вам ще в
перспективі на ту саму модель роботи з
редут самі вже навряд чи
ви шукаєте навчальний заклад у мене можу
битися
якщо туди на
довіряючи це таке циклу чого ти за нас
правді
там ще будете з проби скажемо в цей ніс
зміни підкорення закони звичка свої
щоб ми якраз мало всього виділи ніж ним
вас серед води буду волосся за
принципам немає віри 1 до 1 то тут
держава не довіряючи ректору ректор на
довіряючи кодек ти його означає все розумний
довіряючись студентам студентами довіряєте
вокал дача ми таке менше тільки всі 1
1 підори
я думаю і красою ключові моменти
фізики нам потрібно заміни ти і я
думаю ще кров за кров вам видаються
мене ти у нас у 2007-му потворності здається
у нас інші функції налагодження консорціум
за мертвої автономії у нас житиму
кого семінару кембриджі я передам
виступав проректор і колими випробував і
владне про нас проект університетської
автономії чорний вдома та нібито і голи
хижачки я була вправо живуть це вінка ж
ще у вас я великий циркові проект для
щоб і право дати споживачі
мови
з традиції cipro ви не люди і до віри
без до wears the щось нічого не робот і у
нас нам це кохання такі приставні до
адміністрації президента щось не називався
закриті від президента ось не буду
ставити її попередні щоб вона не
увійшло в історію
ось я каякер гострота нас проводитися
тільки пробачиш і людей не так велика
require країн ось і вин за мною і сидіти
в аудиторії з витасика ж віднімав і тут
каже продавимо
амінка ж таке поняття наймаємо нашим
мовою зручності ось те добиратися
страшного вибуху я думаю ще ми якраз
по ній ти їж лихом адміни 100 сумки
у
в академічний спиною